this is a production of cornell
university
so in this presentation we're going to
go over four things we're going to go
over very briefly what is a weed
why bother with weed id
some weed id basics so some botanical
terminology that will be useful for you
to know and that i will use some of this
terminology in a later section of this
presentation and also this terminology
is often in field guides and other books
that are
useful resources um some important weeds
in tomato production and then end it off
with some resources that um can be that
will probably be useful for you to have
in your operation
so to start
let's talk about what is a weed
so
a weed simply is a plant out of place i
i sort of joke with people that one of
the reasons why i chose wheat sciences
i'll always have a job because as long
as there's humans there will be wheat
so
it can be it's a plan out of place and
that can be out of place in time so an
example of that is let's say you planted
uh beans in your field
last year and this year you planted
tomatoes if a bean plant came up in your
tomato field you would probably consider
that being planted weed
versus it can be a a plant out of place
in space so it can be out of place
spatially so in this picture you see the
grass that encroached into the gravel
pavement um the paving or it could be
uh prostrate not weed that goes into
your tomato field or whatever so it's
just a plant that is out of place
and
the next thing i want you to think about
is which you are as many of you have
already answered that whole question um
is why why should we why bother with
weed identification why is
weed identification important this is
something i want you to think about
throughout this whole uh workshop
throughout this present this section of
the workshop um
i think if we if we can bring that whole
back up and just show i think everyone
has already answered that question so we
can just
look at that perfect
so we see yes exactly
you we no one answered i don't think i
should even bother with this which is
lovely to hear um it's interesting to
know the information i'm happy to see
that as well you like to know
something's a native species and the big
one that was very popular was it allows
you to tailor your management decisions
and that is that is really important to
to read identification and also read
management so read id or read
identification is simply the process of
identifying weeds pretty simple um and
you might wonder well why bother with it
and y'all have already identified that
it allows you to know thy enemy not to
imply that weeds are an enemy but by
fully by understanding a weed's biology
so it's life cycle it's reproduction
it's growth habit all these things it
allows you to better select um
appropriate control methods um and also
make the decision of do you need to
control this so on the
left side of your screen you should be
able to hopefully you can see my my
mouse
on the left side that's virginia creeper
on the right that's poison ivy if you
brush against virginia creeper nothing's
gonna happen if you brush against poison
ivy there's a good chance you're gonna
get a rash so weed identification
is sort of
i like to think of it as the first step
in in management before you can manage
your problem your weed problem or your
reach circumstances however you want to
talk about it you need to be able to id
the weed so weed identification i like
to think of it as the foundation for
weed management is in control it is the
door that allows you to enter into the
management technique spaces
so next we're going to go through some
botanical terminology basics so this is
in no way an exhaustive list of
botanical terms rather they're terms
that you should be
uh familiar with and have a grasp on um
there are terms that will come up in
this presentation again in some examples
of weeds that are important in tomato
crops but you'll also see it in field
guides and in other resources that may
be helpful to you
don't worry about memorizing these and
if you if there's a new term that you're
not particularly familiar with don't
worry about like oh i really have to
just get this in my head now um a pdf
with what i like to call my weed id
cheat sheet it's a terminology cheat
sheet will be sent out to you later so
another reason to fill out that dec uh
poll
so the first thing we're going to start
with is talking about life forms
specifically monocots versus dicots but
before we can make the talk about the
designation between these two life forms
we have to go over what is a connotation
so a cotyledon this is a cotyledon here
um on your picture
it's an embryonic leaf in seed bearing
plants
where they have one or more of them
which are the first leaves to appear
from a germinating seed so the two main
groups as i alluded to before are
monocoques and dicots monocots are
flowering plants that are characterized
by seedlings with one cotyledon their
leaves have parallel veins and their
flower parts are typically in multiples
of threes so think grasses in other
grass-like
plants like lilies for example versus
dicots they're also referred to as
broadleaf weeds those are flowering
plants that are characterized by
seedlings with two cog leadings as you
can see here if you've ever planted
beans and you see those two very
succulent
leaf looking things come out those are
your cotyledons um not they're not
technically the true leaves um the true
leaves typically have branched venation
so branched veins and then their flower
parts are in
multiples of fours and five typically
the next thing we're going to talk about
is life cycle
and to do that we're going to start with
annuals there are two main groups of
summer annuals and winter animals but
the thing that ties them together is
that they both complete their life cycle
in one year or less so starting with
summer annuals that's a plant that
completes its life cycle in one growing
season
so some common examples of that going
from the most left picture to the middle
to the center of large crabgrass you've
probably seen this a lot in tomato
fields lamb's quarters uh in power
amaranth
as opposed to a winter annual which
pretty much typically survives six to
nine months and what it does is it
germinates its seed in the fall of
winter then it overwinters and survives
through the winter um a lot of times
under snow cover but not necessarily
needed and then in the following growing
season it sets seed and then it dies
so the two examples we have here are
shepherd's purse and then also common
chickweed
the next life cycle we're going to talk
about are biennials so that's a plant
that requires two years to complete its
life cycle so starting from left going
from left to right in the first growing
season the seed germinates and only
produces vegetative structures typically
a rosette so in this picture this is a
picture of bull thistle um and that goes
that that sort of
round uh
grouping of leaves is typical of a
rosette and then in the following year
after a period after of vernalization
which vernalization means a cold period
required for flowering the plant flowers
it sets seed and then it dies so on the
right we can see that's a picture of
wild carrot of a wild carrot humble or
the flower clusters
um and that is
typical of the second year of growth and
then in the middle that's yellow rocket
um
that is a another common biennial weed
uh brassicas for example are often
biennials
at least brassica wheat
and the final life cycle we're going to
speak about today are perennials so
perennials are plants that survive more
than two years and there's two main
groups simple perennials and vegetative
perennials so starting with simple
perennials they reproduce naturally only
from seeds
um but in they normally do not reproduce
vegetatively so they can have different
root cysts like root
structures for example the one on the
left uh broadly plantain
it is a
simple perennial that has a fibrous
fruit system if you pull it up you're
not going to really see a taproot as
opposed to dandelions which i have a
feeling everyone here is familiar with
and has tried pulling up a dandelion
before they have a pretty serious tap
root
the other group of perennials are
vegetative perennials also called
creeping perennials so they can
reproduce through seed but they can also
reproduce through vegetative means so
that also means that after you destroy
the top growth they can also
regrow from underground organs and
spread
um an example of that is canada's
thistle so this is a a picture of a
canada thistle rosette
on the left and then this is it after
once it's shot up a shoot and it's
flowered um it's really important to
know what a biennial is versus a
perennial especially for management
decisions
one uh a management decision that works
best for a buyer and you might not be
the most effective one for perennials so
for example you see here this is
canada's thistle if i go back to the
previous slide this is both this or both
thistle is a biennial canada thistle is
a perennial they look pretty similar to
each other
the next thing we're going to talk about
is growth habits so this different
growth habits but we're going to focus
on five here
starting with upright which are plants
that grow
mostly upright they're also you might
see them referred to as erect infield
guides there's clumping which are
plaques that have a mound-like habit and
tend to be equally wide as they are tall
they're spreading plants they also might
be called prostrate plants and they have
a sort of horizontal spreading growth
habit
there's vines which climb requires um
structure
especially once they get older to
support though they might be
self-supportive initially and they climb
things other plants they climb fence
posts poison ivy would be a really good
example of a vining plant and then
there's rosettes which are roughly
circular clusters of leaves that remain
close to the ground surface
um the final section on botanical
terminology that we're going to go over
today is really our is related to
reproduction so the one thing i want to
say before i talk about the different
structures is that plant parts are total
pollen so what i mean by that is that
they have the ability to grow divide and
differentiate into an entire plant from
a plant part
so if you've seen uh when people take
leaf cuttings and they put it in water
and then they grow a whole plant from
that that is that is an example of that
and so the main reproductive structures
i'm going to talk about
today are seeds stolens rhizomes and
tubers
i'm not going to talk so much about what
a seed is i think everyone here has a
good understanding of what what is a
seed what it does
um so starting with stolens
that is the second picture from the left
um stolen they are a modified stem that
runs above ground and they can reproduce
another plant on it so as you can see in
this photos this
yellowish white part that's pointed out
with the arrow these are the stolens
as opposed to rhizomes which are also a
modified stem but as opposed to running
above ground they run underground and
could produce other another plant from
it so this is a picture of crack grass
right here and
these white whitish yellow
root looking things are technically not
roots they are actually stems and if you
cut a piece of this and it gets in
another part of your field it might grow
another quackgrass plant and then
finally tubers which is another modified
stem um you see this with a yellow
nutsedge and it's thickened and
can grow a new plant um in over winter
so
that's pretty much just a recap of
terminology you again you don't need to
have everything memorized a cheat sheet
will be provided to you and these terms
will come up again in this presentation
so you should at least be aware of them
and then as you learn more
have a very good grasp of it of life
form terms life cycle terms
growth habit terms and reproduction
terms
so
now we're going to switch gears in this
presentation and we're going to talk
about examples of important weeds in
tomato production in new york i'm going
to go through five broadleaf weeds in
one monocots that you've probably seen
in your fields um and tell you about a
little bit about the biology and then
some good ways of being able to tell
this apart from other plants that may
look similar to it
so to start we are going to go
alphabetically and we're going to start
with common ragweed
common ragweed
ambrosia artemisifolia it is in the
aster family so that's the same family
as sunflowers it is a summer annual
broadleaf see the terms have already
come up
it's an upright plant that has a branch
it's branched and it has alternate
leaves so
i'm going to explain further as i go
forward and the leaves are deeply lobed
so they're sort of fern like they're
fine
it has a germination period of may to
june generally and it can flower all the
way from august to october and this
plant typically grows to about one to
three feet in height when mature
one fun fact about common ragweed is
that a lot of people when if you get
spring allergies or get hay fever a lot
of people blame goldenrod well
actually common ragweed tends to be
responsible for a lot of hay fever as
opposed to go to wrong
unless you're like my mother and you are
allergic to both
if that if so i'm sorry
so some key characteristics about common
ragweed we're going to talk about the
seedling stage
it has round two oval cotyledons
and then the first true leaves are
pretty
pretty well dissected they have these
very deep leaf margins and that's pretty
um special about common ragweed
seedlings you have these round to oval
cottons and then these very deeply cleft
leaf margins the young leaves are
opposite so that means that they are
right across from each other but as the
plant matures they become alternate and
the leaves are hairy on the upper and
lower surfaces if you can if you're
looking at the photo you can see some of
those hairs coming off the stems in the
leaves so the big thing about common
ragweed is it has very deeply cleft leaf
margins in margins i mean edges of
leaves
for the mature plant it has a shrubby
appearance appearance um the stems are
densely covered with rough hairs and the
leaves are mostly alternate as you can
see here
and the leaves um continue to be deeply
well dissected and fern like as it
matures so this is a picture of a common
ragweed leaf on the right and you can
see that it almost reminds you of
referring
next
we're going to talk about red root
pigweed
red root pigweed or amaranthus
retroflexus it is in the amaranth family
so that's the same family that's all
your pigweeds um your lamb's quarters
are in that family it's a summer annual
broadleaf weed as well
it has a upright growth habit in its
branch as well and the leaves are
alternate uh it egg too oval shaped
it
its germination period is from late
spring to early summer and the flowering
period
is pretty extensive and can begin as
as um early as late june this plant can
get pretty big so pigweed plants can
flower all the way from about 10 inches
tall to
it can grow six and a half feet tall
so it's a pretty robust plant
it's seedlings um are hairy and it has
pearl green stems
the leaves are um it has lancelet
meaning spear-shaped um cod leadings
that are red to purple on the undersides
and the leaf margins of the true leaves
are green in wave um the leaves are
green and the margins are wavy so as you
can see comparing ragweed on the top
with red root pigweed on the bottom you
can see ragweed has these brown cotton
leadings and these dissected leaves
where red root pigweed has these
spear-shaped cotyledons in sort of
egg-shaped
leaves it has a notch on um
the leaf tip but which is pretty
somewhat special to redwood pig read but
it is not exclusive to the species there
are about
seven or more pigweed species in new
york and they look very similar to each
other as seedlings but become more
distinct as they mature
and
as for a mature plant they have very
hairy stems so you can see on the right
this is a red blue pigweed stem versus a
power amaranth stem
it they are they are quite hairy um it
has smooth oval to diamond shaped leaves
with um wavy margins still and the
underside of the leaf is a dull green
with a white mid vein and then a good on
the one another thing that's sort of
special about redwood pigweed is that
it's it's inflorescence which is a
cluster of flowers tends to be pretty
tightly packed and stiff and grow to
about two to eight inches long as
opposed to being a bit more um open and
sparse compared to powell amaranth and
some of the other pigweeds
moving on from there
we're going to talk about common lamb's
quarters
so common lamb's quarters also called
also
peanut podium album is also in the
amaranth's family and it's another
summer broad leaf weed it is another
upright plant that has um that is
branched and it has alternate leaves
that are triangular shaped so as opposed
to your pigweeds that are more dime end
in oval shape these are more triangular
his germination period is throughout the
period i mean sorry throughout the
season however it peaks in spring and it
typically flowers from may to october
and this plant grows from two to three
feet in height but it can also be very
tall as well i've definitely stood next
to um common lance quarters that were my
height if not taller so
common lambsquarters are often confused
for pigweeds and vice versa in the
ceiling stage they have similar leaf
shape but there are some differences
that will help you identify these um
differentiate these two weeds so
starting
um the pigweed cotyledon is on the left
in the common um lamb's quarters
cognitive is on the right um the
landscape is cotyledon tend to be a bit
more linear oval so i tend to think of
a
a rectangle with rounded edges where the
pigweed totaling is tend to be a bit
more spear shape
um also its leaves common landscapers
leaves are more triangular and they have
this sort of graininess on the surface
on that graininess is due to the
presence of glandular trichomes so
basically they're little leaf hairs and
sometimes they might have a red edge to
it um
where as opposed to pigweed leaves that
tend to be oval to diamond shaped
and they are smooth as opposed to
grainy on the surface
here's another picture of a common um
lamb's quarters plant um this is a leaf
and this is uh the infla the
inflorescence and again the they are
simply trichomes or little leaf hairs
next the next two weeds we're going to
talk about are solanaceae sweets so they
are in the same family as tomatoes they
look similar to tomato plants but they
are different so to start with that to
start we're going to talk about hairy
nightshade
so
hairy nightshade or solanum um
um solid folium it's in the tomato
family just like peppers and tomatoes it
is another
um summer annual broadleaf weed it is
upright and branched and it tends to
have alternate hairy leaves with sort of
wavy if not tooth margins it germinates
from mid spring through the summer and
typically flowers in mid-june to later
in the summer it grows to about one to
two feet in height but can reach three
feet
um tall and the stems and fruit of hairy
nightshades um are toxic they are you
should not consume it when it is toxic
to animals as well um as you can see the
these flowers look very similar to
tomato flowers
so starting with this the seedling
hairy nightshade typically has egg shape
to land seal it or aka spear-shaped
cotyledons so you can see this this is a
picture of the cotyledon up close
it has hairy leaves and stems and the
young leaves are often oval
with wavy or toothed leaf margins
so these are two pictures of uh carried
nightshade leaves
as opposed to the mature plant so on the
bottom right that's a mature hairy
nightshade plant um it's it continues
being hairy into maturity with the stems
and leaves being covered with um
sticky spreading hairs the leaves
continue to be uh egg shaped to lancelet
and it has fine hairs on the underside
of the leaf vein
um the leaf margins um tend to be
lightly toothed
or entire
and it has five four to five white plus
flowers per flower cluster
in the i'm i am saying i am knowing the
flower flower color for a reason because
that's another way that is that is
another good way to tell
carry nightshade apart from eastern
black nightshade which i'm going to talk
about next
in the this is a picture of the berries
on the left
so
um
eastern black night shade also called
solanum for the anthem it's another
solanaceous weed i eat another um weed
in the tomato family it's another summer
annual broadleaf weed it has an upright
growth habit um it's branched with
alternate egg shape to triangular leaves
it germinates from mid spring through
the summer and it typically flowers in
mid-summer about five to ten weeks
post-emergent it will produce fruit
until frost and like hairy nightshade it
grows to about one to three feet in
height and again it is toxic it has
toxic fruits in stems um
and it is toxic to animals
so starting with the seedling it has
eggs shaped to lance here like
cotyledons but you can see the
catalinians are a little bit fatter at
the base
and the leaves have green upper surfaces
but the underside tends to be green to
purple with very prominent veins um
the stems might have a red hue but the
big a very good way to tell
hey um eastern black nightshade from
hairy nuts shade and also even tomatoes
is it is not hairy it has a smooth
um surface
moving on to
um the mature plant
it continues being hairless
in um maturity you might see a few
occasional hairs but it's nowhere near
as hairy as hairy nightshade so it has
hairless stems and leaves
um the leaves tend to be elliptical
another word for oval to triangular with
these gravy to tooth leaf margins
the underside of the leaves continue to
be red to purple and then regarding the
flowers they tend to be in clusters of
four to seven and they
are they droop and are often white to
purple so if you see
purple
flowers that are in drooping clusters
and look like tomato flowers there's a
good chance that you're looking at
eastern black nightshade as opposed to
hairy nightshade
the last weed we're going to talk about
today is our soul
um it is yellow nutsedge
so that its scientific name is cyperis
esculentus it is in the cyperaceae
family
it is a vegetative perennial monocot
that spreads by rhizomes and tubers this
um it tends to have a clumping growth
habit that's also upright and it has
flat to v-shaped leaves i'll have more
pictures of that the big thing
that i really want to impress upon you
is this is not a grass
sedges have edges that's a good way to
remember if something's a sedge versus a
grass so that sort of v-shape with that
has edges it's most likely a sedge that
you're looking at um it's germination
period is from late spring to early
summer and it typically grows to about
eight to 36 inches in height
so as a seedling it um the shoot emerges
as three glossy
light um light green grass like leaves
it is pretty these are pictures of it
over here
they are pretty um
light in color
so i they almost remind me of like if
you remember crayola crayons and they
had that lime green it's often it's that
color it's not a very deep green
um the leaf blades are
flat to v-shaped and it also tends to
emerge from its sheath that is this
right here in a triangular um
shape
as you can see the shoot base is
triangular so if you have something
that's triangular like that it's
probably a sedge remember said sedges
have edges
the mature plant um is long and tapered
and it has sharply pointed leaves it
won't puncture you but it can puncture
black plastic in landscape fabric
as a prominent mid vein in its
inflorescence or flower clusters are
yellow and have this bottle brush shape
and it's
in clusters of spike lips
it reproduces by rhizomes and tubers in
season it's mostly reproducing by
rhizomes that is these right here and on
the end you see tubers and then one
mature produces uh brown to black scaly
uh
tubers
so
those are all the weeds that we're going
to talk about today i just want to
reiterate um and further impress upon
you that weed identification is key to
effective weed management
by understanding the biology of a weed
you are it you are better able to tailor
your management techniques to the weeds
that you have in your field so
we're talking about ipm today and
integrated weed management is a part of
iwm but before you can go into thermal
management or cultural management or
mechanical management or chemical
management
you should know
what the weed is the weed idea is the
door to these techniques for example
if you know that something's an annual
then you have a better idea that it will
probably respond better to
mechanical reading as opposed to a
premium annuals tend to be controlled
better by mechanical reading than
perennials do um by being able to tell
something's a grass versus a broad leaf
that's really good to know because if
you utilize thermal weeding on your
property and your in your fields grasses
tend not to respond as well to thermal
readings and examples there are more and
more examples so
just if i if anything today that you
learned is know that weed id is the
doorway to other weed management
techniques
so on this slide we're almost done um
these are examples of further resources
that will um are could be useful for
your operation the two that i want to
highlight are weeds of the northeast
it's a i actually have my coffee right
here hopefully it shows up
um
it's a really good book it's a field
guide it doesn't really tell you
anything about management but it has
keys in extensive
um list of weeds with very good pictures
they're releasing a new edition i think
later this year and another book that i
think is very useful and i used it um
both weeds of the northeast and manage
our weeds on your farm this just came
out um last year
it's a really good book um it not only
talks about some common weeds and how to
identify them but it has sections on
management techniques as well most of
the book is on management itself
um i want i would put a link in
on the chat um you can buy a physical
copy but it's also available online on
sarah's website for free the pdf of it
so you don't have to uh pay for a hard
copy if you don't want to either
so
that's all i'm going to talk about today
thank you so much for your time
and uh thank you veg expo for having me
and uh if you have any questions i am
more than happy to answer them
so yeah we'll uh
transition from the weeds to the insects
if it's not one thing it's another um
and in particular i'm going to focus
this 15 minutes hopefully i'll keep it
within 15 minutes i'm going to try
on uh on the stink bugs which i think
deserve a little talking time because um
i think we've got some emerging issues
so we'll get right into it um but again
thanks for the invite
and um
okay so the first thing hopefully we're
all on the same page we kind of
know what a stink bug is uh maybe you've
got one flying around your house right
now that's that's uh something that some
of us have grown accustomed to but um
we kind of have a search image of what
we're talking about with stink bugs but
um there are multiple species and
several of which can be
pests of tomatoes in fact um we put out
a field guide to stink bugs that
most of the ones you're going to find in
new york are in this field guide that we
we're in a second edition now it's a
little pocket-sized
flip guide um
maybe you can get one from the northeast
ipm center i know they still had uh
still had some but anyway if you're real
curious about identifying your species
um that might be helpful we've got
a lot of brown ones a lot of green ones
um not gonna get into too many species
uh delineations because really the truth
is
most of the stink bugs are kind of
similar with regard to what they do and
and how you manage them so we're just
going to call them stink bugs and
what they do um well what they don't do
is chew holes so if you've
you've got something attacking your crop
and
there's holes chewed in the leaves or
there's holes bored into fruit then
that's that's not a stink bug
um
stink bugs have piercing sucking
stylets that are in a
pro proboscis and and what they do is
you can see the one in the top there um
out one of the stylets comes some
digestive enzymes that will liquefy the
plant tissue
and then there's other style it's like a
straw that will
that will suck it up so all stink bugs
are feeding this way all bugs are fading
this way
and what's left behind are the the
results of that feeding which
can mark up the tomato fruit um as you
can see in the bottom right um if you've
got a potting
vegetable plant like edamame or
something then the seeds won't develop
or they will be scarred inside of that
pod so they can do a lot of things so
that's that's one thing what they do
how they do it
and
tomatoes are definitely one of those
crops that that stink bugs will uh you
know it's possible that you didn't even
see them out there but you see their
damage and you start seeing that maybe
before you even realize
that these things have found that crop
they'll start feeding when the
even when the fruit's green and
developing and then when it ripens you
get these ugly marks um
from where their stylets were inserted
so the other thing that's true about all
the stink bugs is they kind of have a
same general life cycle which is egg
masses are laid in these little tiny
barrels in a in a group and
these are typically laid on the
undersides of leaves and trees are
very common sites for
the ova position to occur or the egg
masses
a lot of our stink bugs are are
tree loving insects but
as the summer progresses they move into
agricultural crops including vegetables
um where the food is
is plentiful and nutritious and and
that's when they come in but most of
them do start their life cycle out
somewhere on some trees and um
these
when the eggs hatch those
neonates or first in stars they're
called
they don't do any damage they don't
really do anything except hang out on
that egg mass
and they are picking up um
important endosymbionts bacteria that
are needed
for them to complete their development
on through the rest of their life and
the mama stink bug has left those
there's helpful bacteria on this egg
mass and they're basically um
taking them up
and and um so you may see this is these
little tiny things on top of this egg
mass that's the beginning of the stink
bug life cycle and
then they progress through various
nymphs that
you know anywhere along that line
they're they're causing damage to uh
crops or potentially so any of these
nymphs can do feeding and then of course
the adults
continue to feed as well the bigger they
get the more damage that they can cause
so there's a there's a look at the brown
marmorated stink bug life cycle but all
the rest of the life cycles are very
similar for for all of them
and speaking of brown marmorated things
really changed with i talked about
emerging issues and this is
you know this is a 20-year old emerging
issue but
um when this thing entered from
from asia it was a you know an
accidental introduction
but has really taken a strong hold in
the in the appalachian
areas particularly of of the united
states um
and uh it it really added a major major
species to the mix that
just the the the population numbers were
more than we had ever seen and the
damage that this stink bug can cause was
way more than we had seen before um
you know here's just some pictures over
the years of uh
you know what the stink boat can do and
the one thing um brown marmorated as
well as
most of the other ones that i showed you
one thing they have in common too is
that they are prolificus meaning they
feed on multiple hosts and actually
prefer to
move about the landscape
looking for the most nutritious
food tomatoes tomato leaves and stems
aren't so much
um a desired
food for stink bugs actually they
they can't complete their development
just on tomatoes they're gonna end up
dying
but
that fruit
late summer is a nice
snack for them and and
that's the thing that you want to
protect the most so it doesn't matter
whether they can do well developing on
the plant they will come and feed on
that fruit but likely coming from some
other some other crops
so where you see the most problems with
stink bugs and tomatoes is
farms that have a lot of different crops
so
organic vegetable farms for instance are
perfect and then they have
a lot of surrounding trees and they're
bordered by woods and this is just like
the perfect storm of uh habitat for
stink bugs they they really
do extremely well in those kind of
habitats
so
starting in 2010 we looked at you know
how damaging have has damage stink bug
damage increased in tomatoes is really
what we looked at since the brown
marmorated stink bug entered the mix and
um
so what we did is uh
over
multiple years in multiple sites of
insecticide trout where we test
insecticides on stink bugs on tomatoes
we looked at um
you know
what's the untreated control getting
is it you know how many of the fruit are
actually damaged by stink bugs and
this kind of gives you a picture it's
it's you know over those years
about a third of the tomatoes are gonna
have stink bug injury if you don't if
you don't do something about it and it
could get much much higher in some years
um
and the later that you got into the
season so
that's enough to say we you know we we
need to deal with this insect so moving
into management strategies and
um
i've worked with this for 15 years now
and and uh some of my other colleagues i
know jim morgenbach i think is speaking
later and he
he's done this as well in north carolina
there's no doubt
pyrethroids
synthetic pyrethroids group 3
sodium channel modulators
are probably the most effective group
and the most
probably the the one that growers are
going to turn to the most because
they're labeled on so many different
crops and there's so many different
pyrethroids this is just a snippet but
there are many many out there and most
of them
do the job really well on stink bugs um
so that's a that's a starting point if
you're a conventional grower
there's probably a pyrethroid out there
that
is a good stink bug material
in addition to those a completely
different other group are the
neonicotinoids ones that there's
regulatory reasons why some
cannot use these
obviously organic growers cannot use
these
but they are another option for stink
bug control these are just things that
we've found over the years and here are
several options for
[Music]
neonicotinoid insecticides all of which
can can get the job done and so here's
just
and i tell you i could put up
at least 20 different these efficacy
tables i won't put you through that but
this is one that i just want to want you
to pay attention to because the story is
very similar in a lot of these trials
this was a tomato trial
conducted in southwestern virginia
where we would spray four times
you know soon as soon as you get the
first fruit out there about a quarter
quarter in diameter or so
that's when we start spraying and then
you know continue that weekly
this is very typical you're going to get
significant reduction in stink bug
damage with any of the pyrethroids any
the neonicotinoids
and then of course products that are
combos that have a little of both like
you see on the bottom there indigo
leverage
that that's really the story i mean you
will reduce it are you going to get rid
of all of it
probably not
there's some little windows where bugs
can probably get in
get in get out do their damage
and
maybe die but they still damage some
fruit
and that's where you're not getting you
know zero uh
percent stink bug damage in some of
these sprays but you you can
significantly reduce it and that's
that's uh that's the story we we've
ranked these um across multiple trials
and and um
you know the bottom line is
you know dinotefuran is one of the
neonicotinoids it seems to be um one of
the best
and you know that's labeled on one
tomatoes and some other crops
and then among the neonicotinoids i mean
the pyrethroids by bifenthrin or
permethrin
ethroid xl all these are actually doing
um
you know probably equally as well so
there's a lot of options out there and
we've tested these and and you know
you're going to get control so we've
actually written a
annual review article on this uh and its
story's not changed
stories also not changed as you change
stink bug species so
it's not like there's anything that's
specific to ground rated stink bug these
are these are true for all of them uh
so
that's kind of it for conventional
insecticides really it's it's
pyrethroids it's it's neonicotinoids and
that's an entomologist who does research
talking how what do the growers say well
we did a survey a few years ago and of
ipm consultants um
and you know most are saying they're
getting decent control with those and
the compounds they are using are
pyrethroids and neonicotinoids primarily
so
that's that uh but now let's get into a
little deeper here
so you're saying pyrethroids and
neonicotinoids are the answer but
there's something that comes with that
so
the positive side nothing's cheaper than
a pyrethroid as far as insecticides go
and it can also provide control of other
pests so
a couple positives there that the
negatives are they're broad spectrum
so when you spray them you're really
creating a clean slate of insects out
there where
you've probably wiped out your natural
enemies um
predatory mites
you know the lady beetles things that
are eating aphids
um
and you know that
know that when you spray that pyrethroid
that you basically drop the bomb and
you could have a resurgence of things
and and no natural enemies out there and
we've seen this over and over again
in fact let's take a look at this this
is a pepper insecticide trial conducted
southwest virginia and blacksburg and
there's three pyrethroids bifenthrin
lambda psi and permethrin
and yeah we got
you know we reduced damage
over half
stink bug damage so 64
or so um
control of stink bugs and you know
that's good your pepper didn't end up
looking like the one on the bottom there
which we were getting out of the
controls
but the trade-off was that we had this
going on we had we had
lady beetles and a lot of other things
that were cleaning up
green peach a fit on these same peppers
and and
when we started spraying those
pyrethroids look at what happened to the
aphid numbers this is to the right
column and
they exploded they got in the hundreds
and
so many aphids that um that's what the
fruit looked like that's [ __ ] mold
growing on
honeydew that had dripped off of the
leaves onto the fruit from all the
aphids and um
you know we we reduced stink bug damage
60 but then we caused an aphid problem
that probably hurt us economically
even worse if if you can't sell those
peppers so if this was a commercial
grower situation so
spraying pyrethroids
although effective
it comes at a price and
you know that's one instance there with
aphids that could flare but depending on
your crop system
you know western flower thrips can take
off on there are some army worms that
are resistant to pyrethroids that
they can flare up spider mites and
things so
that's
we have an answer and it may not be the
best answer because um of some problems
that can happen
another thing we looked at was
well if you can use the neonicotinoids
and neonicotinoids are great as soil
insecticides
because they're systemic they can move
through the
plant up into green tissue
would that work against stink bugs we
were really curious because stink bugs
kind of attack the fruit that's not
where
a lot of the neonic is going to be it's
going to probably be in green tissue
but we tested these put through a
chemigation system we looked at them in
peppers and tomatoes and just to see can
you reduce stink bug damage
by applying a neonicotinoid through
through congregation
and you know this is published work um
we did in collaboration jim wagon back
at nc state my student john agner um
we did it in peppers and tomatoes and
the answer is yes
all the neonicotinoids from
imidacloprid down to dinotefuran
diamethoxam they all
significantly reduced
stink bug feeding on the fruit
when applied through through chemigation
there's peppers
and there's tomatoes
so
you know we were we were let me go back
to that slide we were actually a little
curious to this and i think what's
happening is stink bugs in addition to
feeding
like they will do on the fruit need to
drink they need to hydrate
and they will tap into the plant
vascular system to to get a little bit
of water it's been shown that
um
stink bugs will drink from the plant and
i i think there
they are picking up a lot of
neonicotinoids because that's where it
would be concentrated and
you're killing them before they can even
feed on the fruit
so
anyway that's an option for some
probably not an option for all as we
have as you all know very well
neonicotinoids are banned in various
situations i know in new york that
you've got your
your banning of neonics in various ways
canada has depending on the state you're
in the county
who you're showing your vegetables to
can maybe rule out neonicotinoids so
you're basically rolling out
a tool
that that can be used for
stink bugs so what this leads to issues
with pyrethroids issues with neonics and
those are the two things that are
working well
we need to um we need to find
better insecticides and better ways of
managing this pest is what that boil
down to
so we've been searching uh are there
insecticides that can fit this bill
and maybe not disrupt the things to the
right there that we might care about um
one thing we looked at over the years
was a insect birth regulator
and these are in products like dimeline
and ryman
and this insecticide actually affects
the insects ability to make its its
outer shell after it molts
and then it dies so
you know the insect won't be able to
molt and it won't be able to make it and
it's going to end up dying and you're
not going to get a stink bug completing
its development and
we looked at these and you know we
published a paper on this and
and yes
these products
that are found in dimlin and ryman
control nymphs
very well um
so the early nymphs and the larger
nymphs you can actually prevent them
from molding
it had no effect at all on eggs and no
effect at all on adults um
and that's where we're at with that so
you've got a material that is not going
to control an adult stink bug that comes
flying in from a tree
and starts feeding on your tomatoes so
it's only going to give you control of
the nymphs once they've
started developing on plants so it's
it's got potential for maybe helping
but it's not the complete answer
we've looked at some some other more uh
ipm compatible
um and pollinator compatible
insecticides that we thought
could have some potential in stink bugs
looked at these through the years
and i'll kind of go through these
quickly here a sale you may be aware of
this is another difference
in a couple minutes
yes
okay sorry sorry okay okay we'll just um
let's just get into some of these some
of these materials so
the bottom line is all of those ipm
friendly uh
insecticides
are
um not as effective as the pyrethroids
and neonicotinoids that's basically what
the story goes the safer and
more ip ipm compatible usually the less
effective it is to control stink bugs
and
there's a trial just last year that kind
of showed that we've got some of these
other materials in there
the best control that we got if you look
at the middle column where we got over
50 percent stink bug damage in the
control
bifenthrin and venom down on the bottom
your neonicotinoid and your pyrethroid
where the best
your best option so
organic growers let me get into uh
i will say all the things that are out
there that most organic growers might
use all these oils and
salts and azeoterectins and pyrethrins
and spinosans they do not work i've
tested them over and over again this
trial shows it
um
they will not control stink bugs in the
field
you're wasting your money
what does is kaolin
which is
you know a a clay based kaolinite
powder used to it prevents sun scald
does not interfere with photosynthesis
stink bugs do not like it a lot of other
insects do not like it
you apply that to peppers and tomatoes
um
and you can reduce your stink bug that
we've actually gotten
as good a control with kaolin
applied weekly
as we have with with some of our
pyrethroid insecticides the gray bars
are the kaolin the essential oils didn't
work too well as you can see that's the
orange bar blue is control
so the gray bar is kaolin and we got
significant reduction in stink bug
injury with weekly applications of that
organic growers can use that
and
that's all i've got i don't know if
there's any time for questions abby but
yeah um thank you tom i i have a
question which is i'm wondering
when
growers what what growers what factors
growers should take into consideration
when they're deciding when to start
spraying for stink bugs
and if you stop unsharing then i'll
start sharing my screen while you're
while you're answering thanks
so it's um
what to look for i i'm sorry i missed
exactly well like
how do growers decide when to start
spraying for stink bugs do you have any
scouting or monitoring kinds of
yeah
you know i had already had too many
slides so i pulled out um
my scouting
because
we have looked at there are pheromone
lures that are commercially available
very very effective at drawing in the
stink bugs onto sticky carts um those
are effective at least alerting you that
you've got stink bug activity on your
farm
we've even correlated some trap catch
with these with um you know waiting
until you get five per
sticky card um
to start initially initiating your
sprays and that that has worked
but really the bottom line is you can
you can go out and just start inspecting
your plants
and
you know if you see nothing then
you know maybe hold off especially hold
off if you're going to be spraying
pyrethroids because you could cause
problems but
when you start seeing stink bugs
you've probably got enough
to i know that's kind of a seed of the
pants threshold but if you see them on
your plants
particularly tomatoes there's a good
chance they're at a level where
you're going to see damage on your fruit
and that you probably should start doing
something about it
okay
well great thank you so much tom
so i am abby seaman i am the vegetable
ipm coordinator with the new york state
ipm program and i'm just going to
quickly talk about aphids
tom already
talked about some of the things i was
going to talk about so that means i can
motor through a little bit more quickly
so just starting with um a little bit
about
what it you know what
how how to best recognize aphids and and
some of the characteristics that we can
use to um
tell one aphid from the other um one of
them is aphids have these cornicles and
they look like little tail pipes on the
on the ends of their on the tips of
their abdomens and they can be longer or
shorter and they can be
the same color as the body or different
colors from the body so that can be a
distinguishing feature
um and the other thing um
is just kind of a
defining a kind of a glossary thing is
these antenna
tubercles
at the base of the antennae
um and whether they point outwards or
point inwards can be a distinguishing
characteristics
characteristics the length of the
antennae the color of the antennae
sometimes the color of the legs
another thing to know about aphids is
that as adults there can be both winged
and wingless forms the winged ones are
the ones that are going to be coming
into your field from their overwintering
sites and then the what we're typically
dealing with on tomatoes is the wingless
form
unless they get so crowded that they
feel like they need to start making
winged aphids again
so mostly what we're going to see is the
wingless floor and then just you know
aphids have piercing sucking mouth parts
they're going to put their mouth parts
in and
and suck up um
sap from the plant
and then they're going to shunt out
tom talked about honeydew and honeydew
is a euphemism for um
aphid excrement
um and and so that's that will drop onto
the um the leaves or the uh or the fruit
and and then that city mold can grow um
and then the antennae are typically um
held back over the over the body
so aphids are small and so a hand lens
is going to be very important if you're
going to try to identify aphids and um
another thing to know about them is that
they're relatively relatively immobile
they're not going to move very much they
might drop off the plant if you disturb
them but um
unlike the kind of the things that i
think most look look most like aphids
tarnished plant bug newly hatched larvae
um they move the tarnish plant bugs move
around a lot and the aphids really just
kind of sit there because they've got
their mouth parts embedded in the plant
so another thing to know more aphidology
is that aphids give birth to live young
um so
there are you know they're ready to come
out there there's no egg stage they just
give birth to live young and they come
out and then they um they develop pretty
quickly there are multiple generations
of aphids per growing season
they develop pretty quickly from nymph
to adult and populations can and can
develop pretty fast
so that there's two aphids um that we're
likely to see on tomatoes one is green
peach aphid
um which is pale green to pinkish in
color the cornicles are pale with a dark
tip
and the antennae tubercles that doesn't
really show up very well in this photo
they tend to point toward each other
these aphids have a very wide host range
you're not just going to find them on
tomato and they're relatively small
um like i said this they have both
winged and wingless adults and this is
what the adult the winged adult of the
green peach aphid looks like
um the other
aphid that we're likely to find on
tomato is
a potato aphid
this one has long antennae and long
tubercles or long i'm sorry long
cornicles with black tips and these uh
the antenna the on tentacle antennal
tubercles on this one tend to point away
from each other
these guys can be either pink or green
just like green peach aphid but they are
they do tend to be larger than green
peach aphid
and it can be important to distinguish
between them because
that you'll see on the handout that tom
and other tom and jim wolgenbach and
other
entomologists in the northeast have put
together that
some insecticides don't work as well
against green peach aphid as they do
other aphids and then just a
photo showing you the wing form of the
potato aphid
so
severe aphid populations can cause cause
leaf yellowing and blighting
the aphids can also transmit viruses
and they can be tran and because
viruses can be transmitted very quickly
after only a little bit of feeding
controlling aphids is generally not a
recommended practice for preventing
virus
infection
um
as tom said their honeydew can cause
problems it can cause the leaves in the
fruit to be sticky
and then also this this black city mold
can grow on the leaves and the fruit
so if you got aphids the bad moves the
bad news is that they can
populations can develop very quickly
high populations can cause damage
including yellowing and bladder of
leaves the sticky fruit and the city
mold but the good news is that aphids
have many natural enemies that can help
keep populations under
control so i i
i would like so my paul was asking do
people see aphids every year or just
some years
how much of a problem were aphids on
your farm
because if if you can help conserve the
natural enemies that are out there
on your farm by spraying only when
necessary um avoiding insecticides that
are harder hard on them like the
pyrethroids that tom mentioned
and provide pollen and nectar sources
that might also provide alternative
hosts for the beneficials
some some years and many years you can
um you might not have to spray for
aphids if you can keep those natural
enemies working
so regular scouting for aphids is
important you want to examine one lower
and one middle compound leaf per plant
on 25 plants
um you're most often going to find
aphids on the underside of the leaf
you want to record the number of aphids
per leaf and calculate the average per
leaf
and also look for beneficial insects as
you're scouting i'm just going to
quickly zip through what they're going
to look like toward the end
and massachusetts is recommending a
threshold of six aphids per leaf which
is a lot of it can be a lot it can be
hard to look at six aphids per leaf and
and not want to get out there and spray
so the question you want to ask yourself
is are you seeing any beneficials out
there because if you're not
um you
if you're see if your aphid populations
are building and you're really not
seeing any beneficials
um
uh that
that's gonna factor into your decision
about whether to spray or not and are
you seeing it's increasing from leaf
week to week again that's going to
influence whether you're going to be
able to wait for that six eight per leaf
threshold so some of the beneficials you
want to be looking for of course are
lady beetles everybody's familiar with
the adults
but not everybody knows what the larvae
look like they look like little black
alligators and they often have some
orange or yellow coloring on them and
also the um the egg masses of the lady
beetles you'll also see those where
you're where you're finding aphids
there are some parasitic wasps that
attack um aphids and this is what the
wasps look like she's um
checking out these aphids to see if
they're suitable for her to lay her eggs
in and then her
uh her larval larvae will develop inside
the aphid
and then a mature uh another wasp will
emerge from these aphid mummies we call
them this is where the wasp has chewed a
circular hole in the aphid mummy to
emerge so you'll find these aphid
mummies
on your plants
another beneficial that we often find in
association with aphids is lacewings
lacewings lay their eggs up on these
stalks and then their larvae hatch and
they have these really fierce mouth
parts and here's a a larger
lacewing larva with its mouth parts
embedded in the aphid and it's going to
suck out the the body contents of that
aphid and fling it aside and go look for
another one they're they're really quite
ferocious predators
another one that you might see is
the larvae of hoverflies they look like
maggots because they are fly larvae
and they just kind of latch on to an
aphid and again they're going to suck
out the body contents and the adults of
those are b mimics but they're actually
flies and you might see them
hovering around flowers where they're
looking for nectar the the aphid the
adults don't do any um aren't predacious
just the larvae
um another one is called an aphid midge
and it's a tiny little um gnat looking
insect
that lays its eggs in near aphid
colonies and then you you'll see these
orange larvae and again they're going to
attach themselves to the aphids suck out
the body contents and move on to another
one
um just one more um beneficial that we
can think about um using help
helping us control aphids in humid
seasons and i apologize i didn't realize
this photo was going to be so grainy is
there's a there are some
entomopathogenic fungi which is just
fungi that
kill
insects
that can affect aphids in
especially in humid seasons
so
you want to scout regularly for early
detection monitor your beneficials
use thresholds to let the beneficials
build up as long as you can stand it up
to that thresh that six
aphid-per-leaf threshold
treat if aphid populations are building
and no beneficials are present and just
another if you're growing in a
for for transplants in a greenhouse or
plants in a high tunnel these
beneficials that i mentioned can also be
purchased and released from insectaries
abby there is a question left over in
the chat about kale and clay versus
pyrethrins i think that's probably for
tom
okay
tom if time if you're still here go
ahead and answer that at the chat
thanks yeah sure we we um
yeah we got much better control with
kaolin
um stink bug control with kale and then
pyrethrins pyrethrins work great in the
lab
um but the problem is in
out in the out in the environment the
sun breaks them down so darn quickly
that there's just no residual and um
it just
they just no residual so then the stink
bugs can just keep keep coming maybe a
day after you spray um
so yeah kaolin's a lot better in our
trials
thank you abby um
so for those of you
who may not be familiar with north
carolina the main campus is of north
carolina state university is in raleigh
kind of in the middle of the state and
i'm in the western part of the mountains
near asheville
at the mountain horticultural crops
research and extension center
and this is a
area of the
state where tomato production is a
pretty large component of the vegetable
industry um i think there's probably
about 3 500 acres of tomatoes in this
probably within about a two hour area of
me
and
actually there's this large field right
here which this grower produces
annually uh is only about two miles from
our research station so it's um
an area where there's quite a bit of
tomato production and it's and it occurs
annually so um
spider mites are typically a problem
throughout most of these areas
if you're not familiar with two-spotted
spider mite it's uh it lea or it feeds
most commonly on leaves
usually on the underside of leaves
although not always and you'll see this
speckling of the leaves and
eventually if populations get really hot
really high you'll see a
premature death of the leaves and
obviously with a premature death there's
you're going to be cutting your yields
by fewer numbers of fruit
but when populations get high they can
also feed directly on
the fruit and they result in you result
in the
gold flecking which you can see on the
right part of the of the screen here
usually that gold flecking does not show
until the fruit or turns white or until
it turns red and the reason it's gold is
that epidural layer on the outside has
actually got a yellowish tinge to it and
they they have sucking mouth parts
similar to stink bugs and
aphids that we just heard about and
they're feeding on those mesofield cells
right below the um epidural layers so
they they're
those cells are basically they've sucked
them dry and there it's an air space in
there essentially so you see that yellow
gold flecking on there
the life cycle of the two spotted spider
mite is fairly simple they lay eggs and
then from that
leg or that egg is a six
um
legged larval stage and then you have a
proto-nymph due to lymph and adult all
of which have eight legs as
a class of arthropods have
and you can see the
the adult here on the left side of the
screen they're about four millimeters in
diameter and then on the right you can
see eggs and uh right down there is a is
a immature as probably a larval stage
right around here and then i'll talk a
little bit later just briefly about this
yellow or this orange mite right here
which is uh a predatory mic called
phytoceleus persimilis
uh now
the the interesting thing is females
that are they can
they don't need to be fertilized to lay
eggs but fertile all fertilized eggs are
females and non-fertilized eggs are
males
and usually in a population
the majority probably about
65 to 70 percent of the population are
females in most situations fewer are
males
well there's a number of challenges to
managing the spider mites
they have a very short generation time
and a high reproductive potential so
they can obviously like all arthropods
their rate of development is directly
proportional to temperature
and so the higher the temperature the
more quickly they develop
and under very warm conditions in north
carolina in the summertime
they can complete a generation five to
seven days but those females can
survive for about two weeks and they'll
lay up to about 300 eggs so you have a
very fast rate of development they also
have limited mobility
and they've they're quite well adapted
to individual or to the hosts
and
this their limited potential for
dispersal really kind of
impacts the potential for resistance
development because there's not a lot of
uh individuals from outside of a tomato
field that are interbreeding with these
to to help bring in susceptible
genes when resistance develops but um i
won't go into that and also on the
tomato plant there's a very low
tolerance for damage as i'll point out
here in a little bit
and there's limited option options for
biological control
which i'll talk a little bit about as
well the and i guess well in terms of
its relative importance spider mites are
are one of the most they're probably the
second most important pest of tomatoes
in north carolina the first being in
more recent years being becoming more
popular as western flower thrips but but
spider mites are a difficult one for
growers to manage
our sampling system is
we we monitor by looking at a leaflet
not a whole leaf and we usually take
that last leaflet on a that terminal
leaflet on a leaf and it's usually
one of the first mature leaves from the
top of the plant you don't want to take
the very top apical understand before
those leaves have opened up and
everything but the first mature leaf
that has uh usually
anywheres usually has like six good
leaflets on it is what we sample or we
choose for sampling and we
will look at ten leaflets in an area in
about three to five locations per field
and that gives you a pretty good idea of
the population level out there
in terms of economic thresholds
this is some work that a graduate
student of mine did about 10 or 12 years
ago
elijah mech
so just to refresh your memory again an
economic injury level is the population
density that
causes damage it's equivalent to the
cost of preventing the population from
increasing
and we've shown that it's about eight to
ten mites per leaflet if it gets above
that the damage it inflicts is
oftentimes more expensive than what
or it's it becomes more expensive what
the cost of a miticide is
um of course that's going to change
depending upon the mindset then the
economic threshold level is is
kind of that population density
at which control measures need to be
implemented to prevent the population
from exceeding the economic injury level
so it's a little bit lower and depending
upon the miticides or the cost of it
ranges from about two to four mites per
leaflet and this was developed based
upon a lag time of about four days
between sampling and when control
measures are implemented
so
this just shows you how
how rapidly mites can increase
this is a typical
popular phonology of spider mites in
mills river where we are
you can see very low and then but once
they start to build up it's almost a
logarithmic increase or an exponential
increase in population growth now just
to show you how low the threshold level
is this is the economic injury level so
it's it's really at the beginning stages
of when this population is building and
the
and that and then the economic threshold
level which i described before is a
little bit lower this is probably about
i think i have probably four mites per
leaflet right here so it's early on in
that population build up when when
control measures need to be implemented
just to give you an idea of some of the
common
miticides chemical control is the most
common approach that we
that are most of the growers in our area
anyways are using
and
these are cumulative mic days during the
course of the season so the higher the
mic number or the higher the number here
the
the higher the population the untreated
control obviously the highest and
i just wanted to point out tom was
talking a little bit before about
pyrethroids danatol is a pyrethroid that
also has mito activity but like most
pyrethroids that have mite activity
it's not the greatest miticide in the
world and we really don't recommend it
here you can see it's the only miticide
that was not significantly different
from the control
what you'll actually see that doesn't
show here is that is oftentimes a
resurgence of of the population
following a miticide application
um
then the this is quite typical for us
this oberon and the alta too much
they're kind of intermediate in their
activity and year in and year out our
two best material materials are acromite
and aggramac
both of them are
they just are the best ones we see every
year
now we've done quite a bit of work
looking at other materials that are more
organically
have more of an organic approach
oils
essential oils
some of these more green materials like
um
uh
some of the maroon bio [ __ ] ones uh
grandivo is one they have some activity
but they're not nearly as effective as
the regular miticides and they almost
have to be applied preventively on a
weekly schedule to to help suppress the
population
um
the other thing that is i think is
important to recognize is that weather
really affects spider mite populations
they do very well in hot dry conditions
and our populations are
are usually
or well often times are really higher if
you've got a dusty area a road that's
coming in that's uh dusty those mites
are always higher on that dust adjacent
to that dusty road cool weather um
oftentimes uh reduces the reproductive
rate so you have a lower rate of
population increase and that's usually
good for the
uh ridic for managing the population and
then rainy human conditions there's a
epizootic
neozagites flordania it's a fungus that
can be very effective and i just wanted
to well just to show you the effects of
some of the impact of weather
i just want to show you how miticides
perform differently in two different
areas where common
product or tomato production areas in
north carolina the mountains right where
i'm located
our temperatures are usually about eight
to ten degrees cooler than they are in
the middle of the piedmont center
we're in the middle of the piedmont
rowan county is one area where we do a
lot of work with tomatoes and i just
want to show you the difference of how
mites respond to a miticide application
typically with the cooler weather in the
mountains which is the white's
population shown on the left an
application of biphenyzate or achromite
usually provides us very good control
and
and because it's cooler and we have a
more humid cond humid environment here
one application almost always works very
well um that's opposed to rowing colony
where the temperatures are much higher
and we oftentimes see the resurgence of
of populations following mitosen
applications so
so most of the growers in the mountains
they'll get by with one application per
year quite effectively whereas down in
the piedmont area it's not uncommon for
two or three applications to be required
to get or to keep them below a threshold
level
the other thing i wanted to expand on a
little bit was this uh
epizootic or this fungal epizootic um
of neo-zaghidis floridana it's a very
effective
uh biological control tool under wet or
under human conditions and
for instance in the mountains we get
it's a very humid environment and we get
a fair amount of rain here
if it wasn't for fungicide applications
we would not have a miticide problem on
tomatoes but
because it's a
crop that is quite susceptible to fungal
diseases fungicides are sprayed weakly
and that basically suppresses this uh
fungal episodic but but very interesting
as soon as you go outside of that tomato
field where fungicides are not sprayed
on a regular basis
rarely will you find spider mite
populations of high densities
so
and this is something both tom and abby
talked or
talked about before pesticides can also
affect mite populations
directly by
flaring mites pyrethroids carbamate or
seven methamyl novoluron middleclip
middlecloper is a little bit less clear
um
some work about 20 years ago in
washington state demonstrated that
imidacloprid
does flareomites i it's i've not been
able to do it consistently um and so i
really don't worry too much about
neonicotinoids flaring lights that much
and then i just mentioned before briefly
um fungicides are
quite harmful to the um
new zagates flordania and
that's essentially the reason why mites
are such an important pest on a lot of
vegetable crops
and as soon as you take a crop into a
greenhouse also and there's if you've
eliminated that humid environment and
rain and everything that's where mites
often time pop up quite effectively too
um i'm just going to end here briefly on
a little bit about biological control i
talked about the entomopathogen
neozygatinia which is probably not a
good option on tomatoes or cucurbits
which are sprayed frequently
predators are though the generalist
predators such as lady beetles minute
pirate buds lacewings etc they're not
that effective of
effective feeders on spider mites you
really need to get to those uh predators
and there are other mites phytocyanides
that are specialized and feed on on
spider mites that are specialized on
spider mites um some of these kind of
i'll call them semi generalist or
nucialis phallus or fallacious
ambassadors cucumbers these can be
purchased and they're quite common
quite commonly released in greenhouse
situations
as well as
strawberries it's become more common as
well
uh one of the most effective though is a
specialist phytoceleus persimilis this
is a mic that feeds only on two-spotted
spider mites and it's so it's it's it's
very specialized as a voracious appetite
it's quite mobile so it's a very good
predator if you can get it established
it's native to chile and it's it does
it's and it's there's resident
populations in the piedmont of north
carolina which i talked about earlier
and there we can actually see pretty
good uh biological control
uh it doesn't overwinter as well up in
the mountains here so we it's not we
don't see it nearly as frequently um
the one thing though
these are recommended to be used at 20
000 per cent list per acre which so if
you've got a my problem and you're going
to put try and treat the whole field
it's gonna cost you about three hundred
dollars per acre
that just uh there's the cost benefit
ratio is just not there when you compare
it
to parasites which is you know anywhere
from six dollars with agar mek up to
about
close to sixty dollars per acre with
with acromite um
so we've kind of used a different
approach where we just released these in
release phytoceleus in in the
piedmont area where we've been doing a
lot of work
and if we put them very early when mites
are less than
than a half a mite per leaflet well
below the threshold level and you put
them in that edge of the field where
they can become or where the mite
populations typically become they will
follow
a population
across the field over a period and in
this particular field it was about a two
and a half three week period for that
phytocelius population to spread across
the field so in this situation worked
well it's a little bit tricky i don't
i'm not quite sure that um
phytoceleus populations in the field are
approached probably it has promise in
new york where it's a little bit cooler
um so that's all i had
to present
if i know if there's any time for
questions or not
i wanted to
one thing i should also point out is
tom talked about
pyrethroids and uh those growers that
are trying to they're that are looking
to enhance biological control
rarely do they ever use pyrethroids it's
been an educational process but we've
we've pretty much got them off of
pyrethroids and all they're doing right
now for
stink bugs are neonicotinoids primarily
venom and actara
and
it's worked pretty well with them it's
it's preserved
some of the
phytoceleus
uh yeah i was just where you had the
efficacy of the different products i was
wondering if that was after a single
application or if you did a double
application to get the hatch
that was uh a single application
usually in the mountains here we can get
by with just
one application so
if it's as long as it's timed right
i will say that
if you got a really large mic population
[Music]
to the point where you almost see or
where you're beginning to see
webbing
it's
it's tough to get it's tough to control
them even with the best of my designs
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu